hey what's up guys mkbhd here at
samsung's unpacked in san francisco for
a first hands-on and this look at the
brand new galaxy z flip so
we knew this one was coming we knew we
were going to get a vertical folding
phone from samsung of some kind there
was plenty of leaks out there and then
we finally got it and now that i've had
my hands on my feelings are very
mixed
very mixed so i've held this phone now
in my hands for maybe half an hour and
i've had fleeting moments with it on and
off for a bit longer than that and on
one hand it feels like it's easily the
most polished and mature folding phone
yet
but on the other hand it still has a
long way to go to be something i would
actually buy and it still has its flaws
so let me just start with the specs
right off the top so it's got flagship
internals unlike some other folding
phones well i mean unlike the moto razer
let's just call it what it is i'm going
to be comparing it a lot to the other
folding flagship phone uh the razer does
not have flagship specs but the z-flip
it does it's got the snapdragon 855 plus
eight gigabytes of ram 256 gigs of
storage and a combined 3 300 milliamp
hour battery which is okay
and it still has wireless charging which
is nice and you've got dual cameras here
one 12 megapixel standard and a 12
megapixel ultra wide these specs on
paper
pretty much wipe the floor with the
razor i'll just say it i mean you can't
help but compare the two
maybe leave a thumbs up on this video if
you want to see a separate dedicated
razer vs z flip video either way playing
with the z flip you can see they've made
some different design and material
choices that make it a very different
phone the main one being the screen so
this is now an ultra thin folding glass
not plastic and you can feel that right
away when swiping around and using the
screen it's not a soft plastic that you
can almost literally dig your
fingernails into
it's glass so that's a great advancement
it's hard it's a 6.7 inch 21x9 display
1080p oled 60 hertz and it has that hole
punch cut out for the selfie camera up
top instead of a notch and much thinner
bezels so all these things make it feel
like more of a samsung flagship than any
other folding phone
but
the crease
the crease to me is still major i saw it
from many different angles i used it for
many different things and there's just
no way around it it's a very noticeable
crease i would say it's better than the
original galaxy fold but here's the
thing since this is a vertical folding
phone and the same thing goes for the
razor because it's vertical folding the
crease is across the center here
and that means every time you use the
phone anytime you do any scrolling or
any sort of using the ui you're
constantly moving over that center
crease and you're constantly
constantly feeling the center of that
fold with your finger so unlike a
horizontal folding phone you really
notice it a lot here and you can feel it
when your finger swipes over it over and
over and over again now i still prefer
it to the razer's plastic display
because that one feels a bit more
delicate and softer but i'm not going to
sit here and tell you the crease is gone
or anything i mean you can clearly see
it and then when we close the phone
the front cover display is the other
different choice so they've basically
just put a tiny
1 inch 300 by 112 display
on the outside of the fold and really
all it's good for is the time and seeing
a little preview of your notifications
some people like me may be fine of a
little extra functionality on the
outside like the razer has so you can
actually go into your notifications and
read stuff like texts and emails
but in the z flip it'll it'll just tell
you you got a text or who it's from and
really if you want to open it or
actually do anything you have to unfold
the phone
but also uh if you double tap the power
button you can actually open the the
primary camera and take selfies with it
and use that one-inch cover display as
like the world's most hilariously tiny
viewfinder it's there it's fine you can
use it i guess but i probably won't i
think most people will take selfies with
the normal selfie camera because of the
final major design update the hinge i i
don't think this can be overstated
hinges
are extremely important for folding
phones and learning from your past
hinges to make better ones is going to
be something we start to see and i think
samsung learned a lot already from their
first chen galaxy fold and the things
that went wrong with it and we can
already see that here in this second
generation hinge the z-flip has a really
good hinge i'd say the best hinge i've
seen yet it's nearly gapless and samsung
says it's put a bunch of small fibers
like a like a brush inside this hinge to
give it even more protection from
anything accidentally getting inside
it still might not pass the j-rig
everything pour a handful of pebbles
directly onto the phone test but it is
another step in the right direction and
then the hinge weight is also really
nice i feel like i could open this phone
with one hand much more easily and it's
a three-step hinge meaning you can fold
the phone halfway like a little laptop
and set it down on a flat surface and
it'll just sit that way letting you use
half the screen at a time and then
they've even built in some of their apps
to take advantage of this including the
camera and the gallery and even google's
duo video calls now i didn't get an
answer on if this is an open api and
other developers can you know change
their apps to use this fold too but it
would seem like a no-brainer like taking
advantage of having a hinge that's this
impressive and keeps the phone this well
balanced from tipping over would be
great so that's three major ways that
the z-flip is differentiating itself and
is in a lot of ways better than some
other folding phones the cover display
on the outside it's different the specs
and the build quality and that hinge and
then some other small things i noticed
the fingerprint reader is on the power
button right below the volume buttons so
kind of like they did with the galaxy
s10e i like that uh and no there is no
headphone jack sorry if you thought
there would be one and the bezels are
pretty thick at first but the more you
use the phone the more you realize
they're necessary for protecting the
glass when you close it like the screen
sits just barely sub flush so when you
close the phone you're not slamming
glass into glass you're closing bezel on
bezel so yeah overall
i'm very curious to see what you guys
think of the z flip to me it's really
fascinating but it has to be a little
more than just fascinating to be worth 1
380 dollars we thought it might be a
little bit cheaper those rumors of it
undercutting the razor started to bubble
up but no it's 1380 bucks but i still
can't wait to review this thing i want
to see what the battery life is like
with the 3 300 milliamp hour battery and
a giant screen i want to see how the
durability and that hinge last over time
these are some things you don't get to
figure out just by using it for a couple
minutes but i don't know i'm just i'm
glad folding phones are actually
evolving as fast as they can maybe who
knows and three or four generations will
have the incredibly sleek thin
bezel-less 120 hertz
awesome folding devices
ipad size screens in our pockets that's
all a big maybe but that's what i hope
we're working towards either way thanks
for watching this first hands-on and
impressions of the z-flip and if you
want to check out the other videos of
the galaxy s20 lineup that also just got
revealed today that's a link below the
like button as well thanks for watching
catch you guys in the next one
peace